vas-y tu arrives à celui-ci y a pas un
chat dans ce trou alors merci merci
comment il va savez vous allez dis pas
ce que j'allais y aller je m'occupais de
voiliers pourquoi vous avez vous n'en
dit pas trop vous nous mettez la puce à
l'oreille de plus du cul sans être vu si
on commence à la syrie ça va très bien
il pourrait passer à aller moins bien
dans un instant puisque chaque semaine
je vous dis que voilà vous êtes le
meilleur animateur le meilleur
producteur aller chaque semaine tu fous
de ma gueule
il avait un talent exceptionnel mais
vous avez un défaut aux scieries léger
quoi je me permets de vous le dire vous
avez une fâcheuse tendance cyril à
chaque fois que vos chroniqueurs parlent
ou que les invités par vous parler en
même temps qu'eux alors les
téléspectateurs le voit pas trop mais
vous faites des réflexions alors
franchement je vous le dis en toute
honnêteté
j'adore regarde il n'ya ici là il a
encore manger de chèque choquait un
petit peu d'or
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous posez ces questions pour les autres
épidémies ou jamais c'est par des petits
copains de france télé il va te défoncer
donc moi quand on me dit on est en
guerre mais on n'est pas en guerre avec
ses murs défoncés même pas ta gueule
aujourd'hui les parents ne gère plus
leur enfant je voulais à celui de cadre
mais un enfant c'est une éponge le p
c'est bob je sais je t il c'est déjà
dire je m'en bats les noms qu'est ce que
c'est que ces mots là je voulais juste
un truc j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
revenus aux fondamentaux et ce qui est
tu crois vraiment de l'année dernière
qui a été cole summum de la théorie
telouet vous faire vacciner famille m
mais lui dans la gueule les universités
ils sont tous gangréner la fin lorsqu'on
appelle la cancel culture comme celle
culture c'est la console culture alors
sinon en guerre où sont les généraux sur
les femmes
effectivement il est oublié de dire oui
maintenant il est comme ministère nice
[Musique]
je vous rappelle juste qu'il ya de moins
en moins de sport à sera tom tracera
thor sera
à tort une phrase une race rats avaient
je veux fait régaler avec l'avocat
fabrice di vizio
vous avez entendu ce qu'il a dit
défoncer la fota que ça passe à
l'antenne à mes convictions
c'est à l'antenne et x6 vous savez s'il
est là pour vous montrer autant dossier
cette semaine j'ai besoin de source gpl
indique a besoin d'amis qui l'aident et
cette semaine j'ai fait appel à deux
mais très proche qui il s'appelle thomas
ça oui alors le public
le club fait le rédacteur en chef de
l'émission extraordinaire fait à l'ordre
public le connaît plus sous le nom de
théo leuthard bas il n'aime pas qu'on
l'appelle comme ça mais vous allez voir
que son nom est bien il le porte bien
puisque cette semaine je l'envoyais en
mission g d'émission je lui ai dit
d'aller de mettre des petits coups de
pression au chroniqueur de votre femme
est en tout cas une chose est sûre cyril
il compte c'est de la part de nouna sa
femme c'est également à wil étaient ils
étaient envoyés de la part d'anne ou la
bombarder c'est très chaud et non
[Musique]
l'émission s'est un peu transformés
c'est de l'info du tendence
d'infotainment tu vois et toi t'as pas
l'info nintendo est ce que tu vois le
truc c'est que tu me fais penser à
olivier giroud tu vois là que des gens
bien
l'attaquant de l'équipe de france soit
et c'est le qu'on aime bien oui mais qui
met pas souvent au fond tu vois qu
est-ce qu on squatte n'est pas côté
d'isabelle parce que comme elle n'est
pas très très bonne tu a brillé à côté
de soi et ça va être un moyen pour toi
de toi pour tes google ça mais le truc
c'est que maintenant avec le les sujets
qu'on avait tout faux pas qu'on ait
l'impression d'être pmu rôle je vais pas
rassembler truc aussi c'est que des fois
de la tendance et après c'est un truc
qu'on remarque les téléspectateurs
peuvent remarquer que tu fais un perso
un peu playboy tu sais j'en remets de
mes les gens ils t'attendent pas sur ce
créneau
tu vois ce que je dirai je kiffe j'ai
pas envie de se retrouver dans un éclair
de génie sur radio vl tu vois tu es très
belle lui tu vois bien que dans les
émissions il ya un manque de stabilité
c'est à dire que l'un d'eux était là bas
le mardi c'est là le mercredi qu'elle a
enfin le demain tu vas te retrouver
derrière la télé sinon ça continue comme
ça c'était là qu'il faut que tu sois
plus aux prix constants en fait c'est à
dire moi j'ai une astuce il s'est
investi de cinéma est tout aussi là tu
peux dire je suis choqué une fois comme
ça il veut dire une deuxième fois mais
plus silencieux c'est à dire je suis
choqué je suis choqué guillaume genton
vous êtes compte par moi je suis choqué
je suis choqué je suis choqué je suis
choqué c'est comme tu es tu nous tiens
on est passé à pattaya ou quoi que ce
soit c'est ce qu'il faut que tu
comprennes aussi pour elle il ya un truc
avec tes cheveux et
genre devraient cesser mois 5,2 à
brienon je te jure le remède soit par
exemple jallet dont ils sont
dégueulasses les jeux thermique un pneu
acheté avec tahiti douche pour pernikoff
donc je sais que je sais qu'au début toi
tu faisais une émission ouverte à tous
sauf aux publics quoi donc j'ai pas
envie de syrte ont drainé pas des trucs
pas très sympathique mais formidable
comme quoi les cheveux sales il tape ltd
mauvais oui il a dit non c'est que les
dites moi si tu me dire ça je défonce
[Musique]
ces gens mais tu sais ça va toujours
bien des mobylettes et était un peu
essoufflée souffler il y avait deux
émissions ont été très fêtée le temps
mais je vais à l'hôtel mont fébé alors
été gentil qui embête un petit blouson
puis comme dans ma carrière
tu as parlé allez ça doit être sérieux
et delphine c'est horrible à survivre
c'est horrible c'est vrai qu'au moment
de solitude derrière nous a appelés
alors il est bien ce que tu me trouves
bon dans l'émission c'est benjamin qui
viennent sont faits en disant tu
méritais pas eu non mais hier il était
là en train de parler toujours fait
il m'a dit que des horreurs et benjamin
carré qui me dit que les citadines mehdi
lui il m'a dit que j'avais terminé dans
tp oui à toulouse en disant mais [ __ ]
quel connard semaine dix minutes
derrière mais un moment le flottement
mise en image mkc jeu et moi il ya un
truc qui m'a choqué il a attaqué olivier
giroud et ça jamais ça mais lorsqu'on
dit que si vous n'avez pas été là on
aurait pas été champion du monde voilà
je le redis j'ai embrassé olivier mais
bien sûr on précise que c'était une
blague mme à propos de nicolas pernikoff
c'est bon cette année sert il vous avez
créé un monstre
j'ai craint vous croyez que vous
recrutiez l'ancien patron des
divertissements de france télévisions
mais en fait pas du tout pas du tout
vous avez créé un shar haut je voulais
dit la semaine dernière et cette semaine
et nous l'a prouvé encore plus
il finira pas cette saison tant qu'il a
paquet
[Musique]
il était une fois un amour impossible
entre nicolas pernikoff est la belle
fille après de multiples échecs de sa
part nicolas a récidivé
[Musique]
et quand nicolas apprend qu'il est sur
la liste de delphine et il fait la danse
de la table mais visiblement guillaume
genton est mieux positionné que nicolas
dans la lys était belle fille super fred
faucher décolorés pour être en haut de
sa liste à deux coups conscient de la
réalité
il décide de demander conseil à la
meilleure relookeuse de boulogne intra
muros
même les femmes ça si parra il a
commencé par la coupe de ruches
oui merci on parlera d'attention jusque
vers on a quand même mireille mathieu à
la bluecar
mais avant la transformation il fallait
qu'ils fassent valider son futur style
par sa promise
mais non bon mais c'est pas gagné
magnifique voilà pernikoff zi veut kane
absolument bon bah c'est bon merci oui
je repartirai pas mais ceux-là c'est
votre fête aujourd'hui le pauvre oui pas
demandé ce que je faisais pour la
saint-valentin annonçait à wisteria très
bien faute d'avoir essayé alors quoi on
finit avec cette séquence star du paf
vous savez tout ce qui se passe pour moi
n'est plus vraiment des magnétos toutes
les petites sous tutelle ou partie c'est
bien tous et bienvenue dans sa carte
green side du pmp et on commence tout de
suite avec cyril qui sait mettre à
l'aise pernikoff avant qu'il prenne la
parole
ouais il permit stuff olibeau celui-ci
ça lui va bien
quel chic ah non mais c'est le chic
anglais non mais c'est nicolas pernikoff
nicolas pernikoff oui et puis l'entente
est toujours au beau fixe entre castaldi
et genton par l'énorme crevard et hagen
va-t-on tu pues le nom n'est pas encore
un toit pour tulle avec castaldi s'est
passé non plus est importuné gage
clochard bâtard dégage
et montiel avec gilles verdez encore
moins
mais pas le croire mais les chroniqueurs
évoque des sujets très profond pendant
les pubs qui travaillait au genre des
gonocoques ndlr alger je connais même un
chancre mou c'est quoi tu des watts non
j'aime tant non ces genres des
champignons dans la gazette vous
demandez peut-être ce qu'écoutent
raymond dans son camion
mais on a la réponse est enfin gilles
[Musique]
en contrebas
une chose est sûre baba c'est resté très
courtois dans ses invités certes il est
chéri dans votre cul excusez moi les
médecins merci merci des cherry si
demain les médecins ont plus est
agréable à dire baba connais très bien
ses invités tu connais tu veux bien
fichu tout de suite de bernard montiel
sont les mêmes chez moi sur les meubles
tout soin médical
on finit avec la citation de la semaine
signée baba bien sûr
cet avis est petit à petit air au marché
tout en expliquant à toi mais petit à
petit on tue fait son miel
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]